[Music]
okay
i have some super adorable photos
of this grandma and grandpa from taiwan
oh
i saw these guys yes yeah well not like
that
you saw them the laundromat one yes oh
[ __ ] [ __ ] i think they're
cute yeah i thought they did this all
on their own and i found out it was
their kids or something no it's their
grandson
like a 30 something year old grandson
who like so he said that he noticed that
his grandparents were just like
super bored at home or like you know
because born in a house in a
bar he's like you know because of the
pandemic and
they own this laundry laundry mat
what is it cleaners yeah and and so
he had this idea like what if they
modeled the clothes that have been
left there like left behind for like
even a whole decade
what i don't understand is people that
leave clothes
at laundromat and bikes just locked up
yeah bike locks yeah well i mean
lucky chain places like that what
like where do you park bikes i was
walking around piston and doing some
like old bikes just like locked up
and i was like how this shit's so old
it's rusty with vines all over
that [ __ ] i'm like that's some ancient
ass bike man
i bet you was albert einstein's bike
damn i'll take that to princeton i bet
she's already i'll take that [ __ ]
yeah so some of these clothes they've
been left since like the 80s even
see why how do you eat how do you forget
that [ __ ] did you die
did you die yeah well to be fair my
parents had a dry cleaners as well
for like over 20 years and then there's
always a sign
that's like if you keep your clothes
here for like more than 90 days then we
are no longer responsible
for it even that's a long time which is
hilarious though because like the idea
of like even
like you put your clothes like on the
thing it's like even 90 days later it's
really just gonna be on the rack it's
not like but they don't call
and say you got your shirt here you
still want it
some people just lose track of things or
you know you like
the sad thing to me though is that like
for example in this
like the way they run their shop is that
if
like you they don't get paid until
people come pick up their clothes
so then they have all these clothes
they're not even getting paid so they
don't get paid first
no i guess not the way they run it did
they sell these clothes then
no in return so then they get some money
no because they they
want the people to co oh so the grandson
he created this instagram page and it
got really popular
that's so awesome ton of followers now
but less than a month ago he started it
and at the end of each post he has like
a reminder like
reminder please pick up your clothes and
pay your bill like
and then so they said that ever since
this started going viral there have been
people
that came back picked it up and got it
after like 20 years though they were
like i think they could sell the clothes
yo they see here's the difference so
they actually have
or the sun has fashion sense yeah
they've all the stars like all of it
matches it's good swag
grandson is like the unofficial like
style yeah like photography the choice
for those socks
and that hat right there are like that's
a choice you know what i mean
and even angling it with that brick
thing yeah behind her is like it matches
the color spectrum like it like that
looks so good
i know i love the composition of the
photos
oh wow yeah these these are really
really good and even just
choosing to put on like very chuck style
shoes you know what i mean
i want overalls
you do but they're girl they're girl
overalls
yeah they are you come in with just
overalls on and your hair tied up you
know it
that's already the goal that's why i i
looked at the style and i was like no
the future but you can't have overalls
on it if there's no dirt
you have to have dirt on them because
you're a mushroom
yeah crystal cell are you serious so i
gotta go get my overalls dirty to wear
can i like be like hollywood dirt and
just paint it
kind of like those distressed jeans have
you heard of them distressed
yeah but that's not dirt that's like
when they like shred the jeans so that's
just
distressed dude [ __ ]
we got overalls in there oh yeah we have
overalls
i'll [ __ ] wear that [ __ ] later dude
yeah go wear them
all right i don't know i miss them like
i remember wearing them and i thought it
was the easiest clothes
ever like as a kid and then i don't know
i just stopped working
i loved it i was so versatile i feel
like overalls was one of the first
uh true fashion pieces because it was
such a choice
to unhook one overall one
yeah it was like that's like such a
choice you know what i'm saying
there's more of a choice than like
wearing a sweatband or like rolling up
one leg or like
tilt your hat to the side undo it yeah
this is like one off
flick little flappy flaps you know what
i mean and just jan sport up here
you know what i'm saying oh you're a bad
i never did that
come on i used to like to crisscross
them a lot too
i had like a fake gold chain you know i
just wanted i wouldn't unhook mine i
would just take it off like the
overall thing off because then i didn't
like how it was like swinging everywhere
and it like hit me
like my hand or whatever the middle part
yeah then you would leave it hooked on
yeah yeah but you would like leave it
hooked on like off your arm right off of
my arm yeah it's stiff kind of swag
see that's a toy suit that is a choice
they're all choices
swag warrior james cage white now that's
a choice
didn't he like ghost on you or something
yeah what happened
but i'm trying to get i'm trying to talk
to him again i dm'd him and i said do
you want to come to america
this is pre-coveted i was like i got
extra room we can hang out make some
videos
me and tim we're going to go half and
half and pay for his plane ticket
and then make videos like zenfones
like china hong kong or whatever his
nipples match your nipples
i know we're like brothers that was you
for a second for real dude
except i think he's a little more buffer
than me but um
yeah but he's scared
like he says i don't feel very
comfortable because i want to stay with
the family that has uh
maybe mom wife mom dad and the children
because with the family that have
kids they feel more safer that's what he
said is that like a
actual uh phone call or is that email
correspondence and you're just like
emulating his voice
no he said it on a video like on a on a
video oh [ __ ]
i feel very more comfortable and i was
like oh [ __ ] dude well
let me stay with bart hell no
i don't want no weirdo in my house he's
not
weird he's not but i want to enjoy him
from afar he's an angel dude right now
he's trying to get a girlfriend and [ __ ]
and we're all trying to give him advice
what kind of advice you guys given
i'm just like hey man like take it easy
dude
he's trying to make he's trying to marry
them on the first date he's like
my mom she's she she's so disappointed
in me because i think
uh she thinks that i can never get
married that's what he said
oh dang my mother always she i my mother
is right i'm so stupid i am so so stupid
that's what he says
that's what makes him funny because of
the pain that he's going through yeah
i'm so
yeah but the pain is just like you put
on yourself and that's why it's so funny
but he doesn't know it i missed the days
where he just ate an apple
for a reward he's going i have an apple
this is a reward and then i'm like those
were the videos i used to like
no he doesn't do those he just complains
all day about his [ __ ]
no girl having ass life
yeah wait till then why did you want to
fly him out here to for him to complain
somewhere
no i want to like chill with them you
want to find out
like do the video again like you used to
perform monkey
i wanted to do that like i wanted to get
the avengers
of all the people that give me joy i got
james cage white i got freaking
nice piece guy the nice piece guy i got
william hung
it's gonna be like a boy band but like
very interesting people i mean like like
a boy band of like you're definitely in
it though right
hell yeah i believe you're the leader
[ __ ] yeah dude i'm gonna be the one
yeah but we're all probably gonna fight
though because they're not used to
sharing the stage
because like i didn't do it with william
hung and i could low-key tell that he
was just kind of like
yeah you're like my sidekick and then
when i was like oh can i take a picture
he totally made me a fan boy like we
have a picture together and he's all
like
no autograph like that kind of [ __ ] i'm
like man
we should collab we're like the same and
then in my head in his head he's like
nah i'm bigger
damn damn i felt it though his last name
is hung though
i know i mean he's been he's been famous
longer than i have and he was an
inspiration but
yeah he he didn't want anything with me
like he was all
out there talking to all these women and
i was just like man
not a woman yeah when you're a pretty
girl like
william hung wants to talk to you you
know not me though
i was like i would have been a way
better friend than those girls but
damn well anyway you know what he did
i had to tell you this before we leave
before we move forward
you know julie's on our good friend yes
he had a picture with her
and he put her on his instagram but not
me
i put a picture with him on my instagram
she's sweet as [ __ ]
she's awesome i'm way more famous than
she is it's not about
fame oh actually i'm not
she's on every single i she's she's on
every single
laptop yeah she's literally i can
literally see her
she's the she's the photo booth you know
the photo booth
app and in the the apple computer that's
my friend
julie that's dope yeah i i haven't used
photo booth app in like dude let me see
since i was that's julie
that's julia oh so she's way more famous
than me oh she's
everywhere then yeah hi julie
listen that one that's our friend julie
wow she's on every [ __ ]
apple computer in the whole entire world
can you imagine
that way more famous she's very famous
but i bet you william hunt didn't know
that because all he was trying to do is
get up in that [ __ ]
that [ __ ] dirty dog damn wow
now he's a dirty dog how many how many
women you think william hunt's been with
how do we end up talking about william
hunt when we're talking about these cute
ass grandparents in their laundry oh
yeah sorry yeah back to that let's get
back to the
yeah let's get back to the hungs they're
so cute
anyway they're really cool yeah i don't
know like hearing the story and i
started following their instagram page
too and then
this morning i i opened the instagram
and then i saw them and i'm like oh
they're so cute
and like but tiff do you think they know
william hugh
they're probably meet up and then he
he'll he'll post oh
[ __ ] i'm not recognized he's only gonna
take a photo with the grandma
oh yeah here we go that's true and the
grandpa's all angry
man i love the grandpa's eyebrows
they're so [ __ ]
epic wait where is that thing yeah look
at these eyebrows
oh it's strong did he dye them no those
are just his
eyebrows oh that looks like dyed
eyebrows maybe because
you know what though it's like what's
his face from shit's creek what is that
one after
you know shit's creek oh the uh american
pirates
oh oh yeah eugene levy levy
yeah his son had the same eyebrows they
look like velcro films everyone you
should know
you know yeah dude that [ __ ] looks like
it's like you want me to look angry
man yeah i can't wait to see more of
their photos
and i'm glad to hear that people are
returning and getting their clothes
and paying their bill because i mean
it's just kind of messed up are you
leaving your your forgotten laundry
maybe they died i said that earlier
well obviously not they're coming back
and getting it hello guys thank you guys
so much for watching all of our videos
and i know it's been a million years in
the making but we finally got
just kidding news merch yep so make sure
you go down to the store below
and you can run around yeah you can get
a piece
of jk news and thank you guys for
supporting thank you
bye-bye
[Music]
[Music]
you